so talk a little bit about the costumes
when you get you've got this script I
assume and you have to look through
there and figure out costumes and at the
same time there's there's a little bit
of debate and I kind of like that
there's a debate about what year the
film is set in because people start
getting picky and of course it's a
Christmas memory in many ways well I was
sort of like late 30s right 1940 you
know just the US had just got into the
war and so it was just those sort of
early days Christmas stories probably
either my second or third movie as a
designer so it was well okay let's get
this the Sears and Roebuck out you know
that's I mean that's how we did it then
you know we didn't have internet we
didn't have all the things we use now to
you know make motion pictures and the
library mm-hmm and you know it's those
buildings you see there's one downtown
yeah it's that one so a lot of the
costumes had to be period at the same
time you had a lot of extras and scenes
like that and we had a lot of dream
sequences right Ralphie was dreaming
forever no bed Bart no like all these
great sequences I mean there was lots of
stuff that we shot that never even got
into the movie like mingle immerse
merciless and oh my god
there was one particularly really great
story about Bob Bob would come in in the
mornings and he would say you know Mary
I was thinking last night and you just
go
Oh No okay well okay what are you
thinking I mean you know I was I want
some in 15 at the time I'm telling you
and and he said one particular one was
I'm thinking that Ralphie should be like
a knight in shining armor I don't know
if you know about this one Pierre and I
said okay and he's 12 years old and I
said okay and he says no no like Don
Quixote like mirrored anyway really okay
um well Bob when do you want to shoot
this he says well I'm thinking about
shooting it tomorrow I was but the one I
do remember though that was cut out was
the Ming the Merciless yeah it was a big
they got the whole other story
it was a big planet and I guess Flash
Gordon was pinned down behind the moon
rock and Ming the Merciless had him and
somehow I got the call to come save him
in my mind but what I really remember
was the tiny silver shiny shorts that
you designed for me to wear waiting
thank God it was cut out of the movie I
was so self-conscious in these things
all this stuff I had to do in the movie
that was the one and you're wearing them
tonight quietly though not on display
but that one didn't make it I did talk
to Bob later about it and I don't think
he tested the movie a lot he trusted his
instincts but he tested it one time and
he said we got something great but that
was the one scene the audience said you
went a little too far I guess outer
space blindness was fine Cowboys were
okay but other space